for destiny or also known as Destiny. He is definable by having
a son who is a neo-Nazi constantly aligning with white nationalist
white supremacist neo-Nazis being able to say that and all these
other slurs as a white guy and also on top of that I guess being
super pro-Israel and procuring child abuse >> It's the
same tactic. It's the same tactic like in a more specified sense.
>> Did wait is Hutch going to
say things one of those? >> I would just love to hear him
like basically go oh Hassan's lying on one of those. This is
like the most competent thing I've ever seen Hutch do. This is
like we found his thing. We found a thing that Hutch is good
at.
>> Uh at Hutchinson says Son the Hun is going to hate his
trip on the Noestra America flotillaa going to Cuba. Cuba. Cuba.
Cuba. Some PR stunt that they're doing. He's going to resent
sharing that small space with the filthy pearls. He's going to
have such a horrible time. Bro, people project onto this guy
like crazy. It's very funny. Kuba Kuba Kuba.
He's announced that he's going to be on some kind of a flotillaa
headed to Kuba
with supplies to try to break through the blockade or something
like that. Some like um PR stunt that they're doing. He is going
to resent having to share that space.
He's going to have such a horrible time, you guys.
Sharing that small space with the filthy pearls. He's gonna have
a such a horrible time. Wow.
Let's let's jump in here. Let's see what Let's see what Hutch
has got here. I'd rather watch him watch Hassan >> 28.
We should talk about this backlash and controversy because we're
gonna see this play out. And one of the most recent ways it has
is you have tons of people slamming political commentator Hassan
[__] for how he might be voting. Because on a recent
appearance on Jennifer Welch's I've had it podcast, she brought
up some hypothetical presidential tickets. >> Let's say
that Gavin Newsome becomes the nominee that we make it midterms.
>> Devastating. Do you vote for him over JD
>> I don't know. I'd have to vote for Gavin
>> I wouldn't blink. What about you, >> I'd probably
vote third party. >> You would?
>> Oh, yeah. I mean, I at that point it doesn't even >> I'm
getting PTSD >> matter like cuz my policy on
is the same as like
>> I You know what, guys? I do think Assan loves hearing
himself talk. What kind of narcissistic loser loves hearing themselves
talk? Can't imagine. >> It is kind of nuts. Like I get
self-conscious when I hear myself talk. Sometimes I will relisten
to
>> what's up
>> a debate that I've had
to sharpen my arguments.
But I cringe a lot.
>> You know, I definitely cannot watch old videos of myself
like it's an uncomfortable. He has watched this same video of
himself front to back like seven times.
>> He [__] literally loves
>> the sound of his own voice. >> Refusal to endorse
the
>> Wait, who do you think watched this clip more, Assan
or Hutch?
>> Yeah. Who loves more? >> He's so for real right
now, right? Who loves more? I think it's pretty easy answer,
man. Um, the reason why I did not endorse Kla Harris was because
encouraging third did things that were not only unproductive
but
>> oh god Phil
Phil if you can hear this I'm going to put this out into the
universe Phil please don't
please don't find a way to
deflect to the same irrelevant points or straw man arguments.
Please don't do it. Phil,
nobody is telling Hassan that he has to support Gavin Newsome
in the primary. Phil, nobody is accusing Hassan [__]
of being singlehandedly responsible for Kla Harris losing the
election. Phil, please don't do it. Phil, don't do it. Phil,
>> also unconscionable. >> And that it prompted a
ton of outrage and a lot of, "Are you kidding me?" with a lot
of people thinking that Hassan shouldn't be encouraging third
party votes to his massive following and some saying things like,
"Insanely irresponsible take given the harm this administration
has unleashed just one year in." As well as, "Can we move on?
>> Does Philip DeFranco just do internet versus like boomers?"
Is that what I've actually never really watched Philly D content?
Is it just internet versus? >> I don't know who watches
Philly D, man. I used to watch Philly D when I was like a teenager,
you know. Um
I don't know who watched him in 20 in 2026. I can't imagine what
the average Philly D viewer >> looks like. >> I like
the Is it still teenagers that watch him? I can't imagine teenagers
now are coming up watching Philly D. That just doesn't make any
sense to me. I feel like it's people who would have subbed to
him and then he just does like the quick hits on things and maybe
they I don't know. I the thing that made it good back in the
day is like you didn't really have deeper versions of any of
this. So if like if it was interesting to you just you didn't
really have somewhere deeper you could go. Now there's like a
bunch of niche content creators. So I actually don't understand
but yeah who knows >> from these left-wing creators that
>> yeah Hillary Clinton staffer once again that openly
said he didn't vote for Zoron Mumani have built a business on
just hating Democrats it helps no >> did he vote for a
Republican did he did he vote in a way that could help Republicans
or did he vote for a
>> Nobody but themselves. You also had tons of people accusing
Assan of being a grifter, arguing that he quote wants Republicans
in office because he gets to cosplay a revolutionary, which raises
his profile and makes him more money. And then separately from
takes on Hassan, you had some pushing back on criticisms of Gavin
Newsome. They're saying, "I live in California, my gay friends
and basic rights. My girlfriend can access reproductive care
and we raise them." >> Of course, Philip is going to cook
me on this cuz he is, you know, when it when the cards fall,
he will be a he will be a professional misunderstander as well.
Once again, Phil, >> I have seen Phil sweep for Hassan.
Well, once his is, you know, Phil, >> you love to see it.
You You love to see it. Okay. You love to see it.
>> His soy faces are crazy.
[laughter] >> I have seen Phil sweep for Hassan so many
times, bro. He's place training Phil, guys.
He's punishing Phil.
You get the treat or you get the shot collar. Sometimes you get
both. He is This is what he's doing, you guys. He is place training
Phil. Philip, I mean, we talk all the time privately. I I like
Philip DeFranco. I'd love to have this conversation with you,
>> but he's not sufficiently loyal
at the end of the day. We can't count on him to be sufficiently
that is a crazy one-two punch to be like, "Of course Phil's going
to
be a professional misunderstander. Of of course Phil's going
to take the side of my attackers.
Of course, Phil's not going to be loyal,
you know." But, you know, I talk to Phil all the time. I like
Phil. I am becoming >> I'm I'm waiting for a thesis. I'm
just waiting for the thesis of the things he's saying. Something
that ties this together, like an idea he's driving at. Hopefully,
he can lay it out for us at some point. >> More and more
fascinated with the psychology of Hassan [__]
every day.
I am becoming more and more convinced. >> I'm becoming
more and more obsessed with the Zan [__] every single
day. Yeah, we know lots of people putting it up for a while.
much. We know [laughter] >> and it might be like when you're
a hammer, everything looks like a nail, but I am I am becoming
more and more convinced by the day that he is like a dangerous
narcissist.
Like a like a like a Ted Bundy type situation.
>> Oh my. Who's the guy in Gana? Who the is the cult leader
in Gana again? What was that guy's name again? Jim, what's his
name? Jim Jeff. Jim Jones. He's a Jim Jones narcissist. All of
this, guys, is calculated, guys.
He's not doing it on a whim. He is specifically choosing people
to make examples of. It is a system of compliance,
coerced compliance. >> Yeah, I think um this is the thing,
okay, Billy D, he's going to watch this and he's going to be
like trembling knowing that Hassan or somebody owned by >> He's
he's a professional misunderstander.
He said that Philly League is a professional misunderstander
>> H is like wow. He's like he's like punishing him. He's
like tearing him down of his entire audience. >> Course
of control. Yeah, it's course of >> through punishment
and reward. >> Absolutely massive swing. Let's see. I'm
not totally convinced that this segment is going to go the way
Hutch hopes. >> This guy is a raging
narcissist. I'm telling you >> with you. I think it would
be a productive conversation. But then as far as Hassan, he's
defended himself in a series of posts saying, "Do you want free
healthcare? Do you want free college? Do you want to stop Israel?
I'll vote for anyone who sincerely believes in making that happen."
Ding, I never said JD Vance is better than Newsome. You want
to believe I said that because you can't comprehend a world where
democracy implies asking for concessions from your elected representatives
before doing loyalty pledges to them like a happy surf. The son
then saying, "Shit libs who don't care about losing to Trump
now want you to obey in advance to their hypothetical establishment
candidate while there isn't even a guarantee there will be an
election 2 years from now." Yes, we want you to commit
to not helping the Republican party win elections. And I don't
think we're asking too much. I don't think that's so much to
ask for. Do not threaten us
with helping Republicans win elections. I think that is a reasonable
ask. Now, using marginalized people as a cudel as Gavin threw
trans people under the bus. And while he had his supporters,
you also had a number of people pushing back at that response,
saying things like, "No one is asking anyone to obey our command,
so please come." Like John Federman's staffer who only recently
left John Federman >> and some others also taking his
>> really like really hang on a minute. Are you kidding
me with this? Hang on a minute. Let me show you guys something.
>> Is he mad about the guy the Federman staffer? Is he
mad that Hassan got up and walked away? I can't tell.
>> Again, John Fetterman staffer.
This guy used to be affiliated with John
Let's tar and feather
who had a positive view
of John. >> Oh, is there like a Hassan picture of John
Federman? Maybe. >> John Fetterman. >> Maybe there's
a Hassan picture with John >> Hang on one second. >> This
is taking a while. >> John Federman staffer guys.
>> Can you believe this guy? He used to support John Fetterman.
>> Yep. By working for him and helping his political will
become a reality. Yep. Yep. Obviously, >> it's his strategy
of
discrediting people.
He shock trains his audience
to discredit people. Uh, so 2022, it's official. I will be the
next US Senator Senator from Pennsylvania. We bet on the people
of Pennsylvania and you didn't let us down. And I won't let you
down. Thank you. This is great. We're really lucky to have him
representing our state. He massively outperformed Biden. Pennsylvania
greater than Ohio forever.
Yeah. Did something happen like maybe you know 11 months almost
11 months after this pretty much exactly 11 months after this
that might have caused people to change their opinion on John
Federman.
Mr. John Federman guys
>> to uh establish who is pure and impure.
>> You thought something different 3 years ago and changed
based on new information. Uh that means you're not principled.
That means you're like a totally disingenuous grifter. You changed
your opinion based on new information. You're a loser for that.
>> Oh, you can't trust this guy. He used to work for John
Federman.
Anybody who had any positive view of John Federman,
that's somebody that you can just ignore.
This is like actually quite sad to watch that it's like so obviously
disingenuous that people don't like John Federman because of
his crazy over-the-top commitment to Zionism, right? And I think
bipartisanship as well in the face of like a Republican party
that's lost their minds. Some people don't like that. Why is
he talking like that? Cuz he thinks he's proving a point. But
this all happened after Federman won, right? people were. But
by the way, sure looks like in 2022, these guys were super psyched
about a Dem candidate winning Hutch. Just so you just so we're
clear, the exact thing you're concerned about, it looks like
they were totally willing to give this guy a shot and were psyched
that he won.
And then after he got in and governed, they don't like his decisions.
They don't like the things he's talked about.
Right? Are we confused? What's confusing here? Surely you can't
find old tweets of mine
praising John Federman. That might be a bit of a contradiction.
>> And as we pointed out, Hassan literally said, "This
guy just left John >> Can you believe these people? I don't
how the people in his chat
get hypnotized by this raging narcissist. Do they?
Uh, mirror. Mirror emoji. Mirror emoji. Hello, mirror. Can we
hold up a mirror to Hutch right now? What? Well, I don't even
know if Hutch is a narcissist. I don't even know if that would
be accurate. I'm just saying I don't know how people in his chat
get hypnotized by whatever performance this is is very goofy
to me.
>> Very, very goofy. >> Did they all memoryhole
being super positive on John Federman?
I was I was I was I was
I bet you Hold on. And I bet you we could find
tweets from Pisco being super bullish on Giant Federerman.
And I bet you we could compare that to Pisco's position now,
which has migrated the exact same way that Hassan's and Mike
from PA has. Would Hutch take this criticism to Pisco? Uh you
wait, wait, wait, wait. Are you saying that you support you used
to support John Federman, you don't anymore? You're disingenuous.
You're like a liar.
Clearly, he'd take the same criticism to Pisco, right? that a
Democrat beat like Oz in that
I had a positive view of John. >> Sorry, I'm saying you
could probably find out find tweets from Pisco saying that I'm
happy that Fetman won this Senate race, right? The same way.
And then obviously based on how Fedman has talked, what he's
done. Pisco's super not a fan. I think I don't know if there's
anybody in Congress Pisco dislikes more than Federman on the
Dem >> Don Federman, >> I'll say the Senate. I don't
know about the entirety of Congress, actually. And then, you
know, new information comes to light and you know, you can change
your mind based on new information. There's nothing wrong with
that. >> The fact that this guy was a former John Federman
staffer, that's enough to discredit him. >> Well, that
he recently left, that it wasn't enough while he was doing all
of the things that he recently left. It was the recency, not
that he ever was.
But the fact that you were aggressively pushing for John Federman
at the time that apparently your audience just memory holes,
that's not that doesn't discredit you.
>> Cool. Cool. >> Because he took it further and
was like a staffer. How does that make any sense? How is that
a consistent standard?
>> Hello. That's so stupid.
Issue with how he framed Newsome's stance on trans rights with
one person saying actual trans person here. Gavin Nusa made a
comment about trans athletes that I don't agree with, but California
is still one of the best places to be trans in the country. See
the difference? You don't care about what happens to us, so stop
acting like you speak for us. Now, with all this, you actually
had Jennifer Welch ending up posting a video in his defense claiming
>> what Hassan is saying is we need to build a party that
has an FDR [clears throat] style impact that
you know what?
that's a good idea. That's a good idea.
Deceptively simple.
Easy. Easy.
Honestly, how come nobody thought of this yet? How come the Democratic
party hasn't thought of this yet?
All we got to do, guys,
is get an 85 seat majority
in the Senate and uh you know, roughly 350 House seats for Democrats.
Why didn't we do this before? What the Why didn't the Democrats
do this before? Jesus, it's so obvious. Wow. I think that was
her point was that that would be really easy and not require
any sacrifice or confusion at all. Sorry, not confusion. It wouldn't
require any sacrifice or or hard decisions at all. Like possibly
saying that I'm going to withhold my vote if you don't like kind
of move more to the left.
>> Brilliant when you think about it. I mean, you just
brilliant when you think about it. really really impacts the
lives of people instead of this slowm moving incremental change
that the current Democratic party always proposes. Number one,
Hassan's not a politician. Number two, >> um, caval cattle
with $10. These people are so irrelevant. Hassan isn't even using
their real names, Hillary Stafer and Federman Stafer. Are we
supposed to believe even Hassan views himself as similarly irrelevant?
>> Hassan gets to think whatever he thinks.
Kurt are there that donation just makes me think is Hutch concerned
that you know he's clearly receiving donations from outside the
US right now like that person clearly doesn't speak English as
a first language is that is that not concerning to Hutch a little
bit >> current Democratic donation >> always proposes
number one Hassan's not a politician number two >> um caval
cattle with $10 these people are so irrelevant Hassan isn't even
using their real names Hillary staffer and Fedterman Stafer are
we supposed to believe even Hassan views himself as similarly
irrelevant. >> Gets to think whatever he thinks. Number
three, there's a large growing number of
>> maybe Hutch might have misread it to be honest. It could
have been Hutch misreading it there at the end. >> And
Jinsey and as millennials that have felt completely unseen and
left behind by the two party political system who hate and despise
how much they suck up to corporations. We have time right now
to have these conversations and to move our politicians to a
progressive populist platform. >> So far as say one of
the reasons that Democrats lose is because they do not listen
to voices like Assan [__] So, it's also worth noting
that during the podcast, Assan did preempt any potential backlash,
claiming that Democrats might lose solely because of him. >> I
am incapable
there is. >> Now would be a good time, Philip DeFranco,
to say of course
nobody was saying that. Maybe some people were saying that, but
that's not what the conversation is about. The conversation is
not about
it wasn't even about Hassan's influence really. It was about
his individual. >> Has Philip DeFranco not watching my
streams? Does he not know the talking points on this >> come
on man >> commit to a strategy of helping Vance win an
election?
>> We can expand on that by talking about his larger influence,
but really any anybody on the left that is talking about doing
that is, you know, that's a [__] problem, right?
Um >> Hutch was saying that until Pisco yelled at him.
Pisco did fix up. He cleaned up a lot of Hutch's rhetoric. Hutch
was basically leaning in that direction a lot of the time. Now
Hutch says, well, it wasn't like it wasn't like Hassan was pulling
in the same direction as us. He might not have affected the election,
but he wasn't pulling in our direction. no singular force in
this country that is capable of making or breaking an election.
And if that was real, then it is the most idiotic thing not to
listen to my demand.
>> I would really love your thoughts. Obviously, with any
election, whether it be local or national, I think you should
weigh the difference between the two >> Did a decent job
of showing both sides. >> I'd love a >> He literally
just showed both sides with no kind of I mean, to be clear, this
is him saying uh harm reduction is correct
without fully like fully fully committing to it. But he is really
I mean this is Phil saying yes, a harm reduction strategy is,
you know, what he thinks that you should do. I wonder if he will
own it though, you know.
That is what he's saying. So just like own it, right? Like own
it. If you think that people should decide the better outcome
in every election,
then you know, stick your flag in the sand, bro. Like just own
it.
That is him weighing in. I have eaten fage foliage with $5. You
should watch and call our Keith Edwards in his Hassan
>> He was also quoted attacking Chorus by Taylor Loren
last year. You should watch and call out Oh, Keith Edwards.
>> I don't that person has popped up on my feed. I might
have quote retweeted them. I don't really know. >> Rank
choice system that brings in more voice your thoughts here. Honestly,
with any election, whether it be local or national, I think you
should weigh the difference between the two people. >> I
think he did a decent job of showing both sides. >> I'd
love a rank choice system that brings in more voices, different
voices. But that's a whole >> I think he did a decent job
because he didn't do any kind of criticism of him. Then I'm going
to vote for the best or least worst of the two top options. That's
why I voted for Kla Harris. Does she represent everything I want
in the >> You know what? That's a Phil W right there. That's
a Phil W right there. That's a Phil W. Now, he could squander
that W by finishing off this monologue with a meaningless, you
know, but not everybody thinks the way they W, which is the most
meaningless thing you can say. So many people do this, but obviously
you know I respect other people's opinions and you're allowed
to have different thoughts. Like I'm aware that I'm allowed to
have different thoughts. Uh Viking with five
appreciate
that a government in a country like her versus Donald Trump would
be the exact same thing with the exact same things >> No,
I'm not saying that Kla Harris would be identical to Donald Trump.
And there are certain areas where the the Democrats would definitely
be >> every area.
area basically maybe there's like 10% overlap on procedural stuff,
you know, >> identical to Trump. It's uh you know Israel
being one of them or at least they don't shy away from communicating
that they would be the same. >> I think she would have
been better on Israel too by the way. I think she would have
allowed for example I think she would have presided over a 11we
blockade. Um Rice thanks so much for the tier one membership.
>> Right. That's what Kla Harris did. >> I wonder
what Hutch bases that on.
Like I I tend to think Kamala would be better because I think
Trump is totally in BB's pocket.
But what part of Kamala's like action or anything that her administration
did the administration she was a part of? What part of that makes
you think that she would stop anything?
>> Someone made a comment that Gavin >> Kla Harris,
the VP, the VP determined our Israel policy when Biden was president.
That was Kamla that did that.
Someone made a comment that Gavin would come on the show if you
said you were >> Would come on the show if you said you
were conservative. Exactly. Yeah, that's my real grip. >> Dems
tend to be less brutal. Um, they don't do policy that's as brutal,
but this is about what Israel is doing and whether or not you're
going to look the other way. And I don't know that Dems have
like failed to or sorry stood tall and like not looking the other
way in any meaningful way. Like I I don't know what's been done
because I I know I think that they would I think Kamla would
be better because I think Trump would let them do anything. But
then when people are like wait why do you think that they'd be
better? Like what did she do to stop anything or what did Biden
do to stop anything? I'm like well he was mad at BB.
I I saw reports that he was mad. So I've tried to argue the other
side of that and I'm like ah there's not really a lot of tangible
stuff there. is I'm positioning myself as anti-Gavin Newsome
and and a conservative MAGA guy so that Gavin Newsome comes on
the show so I can grill him on some of his positions. >> He
would decimate Hassan. He would decimate like embarrass. >> I
do think that we should be having these conversations especially
now far away. Was uh was Harris talking about building a hotel
there? Nope. That's why in my opinion I'm like oh Trump would
do like I think Trump will write blank checks essentially. But
again in terms of what KML has done I I don't know. I I don't
know how you could evaluate like how much better she'd be, at
least in the short term. >> Hey, from >> that's not
a conversation. That's a
What kind of a conversation is supposed to follow you saying,
"I will help Vance win if the nominee is Gavin Newsome." A conversation.
What What are we talking about then? >> The The I feel
like I'd like to if I was going to try to debate like any of
these guys on this stuff, I feel like I'd like a topic that's
not just
about mind readading Hassan. But I I just feel like given his
statements afterwards, given his statements on the podcast, I
think it's totally inaccurate, obviously.
Uh, will Hutch not talk to you? Yeah, Hutch won't talk to me.
But I could probably talk to Pisco or Josiah about it,
but Hutch Hutch wouldn't talk to me.
>> yeah, actual election so that we can nip this in the
bud. So when people chirp at me to to, you know, get clicks or
whatever the you can keep doing that if you want to do that,
but I do think that I should have a conversation with like the
Midas Touch guys, Pod John's. Uh, I'll go on neutral territory
like that to talk to some of these centrist liberals. Like I'll
I'll duke it out with Trey Eastston even though he's a irrelevant
figure overall. You know, >> no motion. He's got no motion,
guys. >> Yeah. No motion. >> I say that there is
like you need to be
>> That's so true, man. Han's got so he's calling him irrelevant
now, but he was freaking out two days ago calling this guy the
consultant class that we need to worry about the consultant class
because they're going to tear me down. They're going to tear
your godking down. We have to get more likes than them on Twitter
and Tik Tok because the consultants, they're going to tear me
down. But also, he's irrelevant. has no motion.
>> Your opinions, by your policies, by what you put out
there for the Democrats in general. I feel like for Destiny or
also known as Destiny, he is >> So I think with the consultant
class thing, he's not saying that he loses to them on Twitter,
right? He's not talking about likes. He's talking about like
behind closed doors. When he's talking about the consultant class,
the reason he calls them that, it's because they have influence
that is not immediately apparent. They're not out in the open,
right? That's why he's talking about duking it out or how they
could like sewer him behind closed doors. That's why he's saying
he has to do cleanup is because he thinks there are people with
more influence than they have like online. They have more influence
behind closed doors. They talk to people who are involved in
politics like low-level staffers and stuff and that can trickle
like upwards or downwards. So he's trying to talk about that
feels like pretty obviously >> by your policies by what
you put out there for the Democrats in general. I feel like for
Destiny or also known as Destiny, he is definable by having a
son who is a neo-Nazi constantly aligning with white nationalist
white supremacist neo-Nazis, being able to say that and all these
other slurs as a white guy and also on top of that I guess being
super pro-Israel and procuring child sexual abuse material. >> It's
the same tactic.
It's the same tactic like
in a more specified sense. >> Did wait is Hutching things
true? Saying
>> I would just love to hear him like basically go oh Hassan's
lying on one of those. Can we get it? Which one of those is wrong?
Arch, that'd be great.
>> Like, here are all the reasons why you shouldn't pay
any attention to the things that this person says. Really, it's
because he knows that people like Destiny are pretty good at
articulating.
>> I don't even know who you are. >> Uh why Hassan
is just like a nonsense, not serious joke of a human being
and uh probably doesn't feel comfortable with the idea of like
defending himself in a conversation with Destiny. So instead,
you do the thing where you just like here's why you can just
ignore them. That that that >> I feel like that's Hutch
saying he'd talk to you, Queenman. I feel like that's Hutch saying
that it would be totally to avoid a conversation with somebody
and totally deflect to some nonsense. I feel like it's him saying
he would talk to you. >> I think so. I think so. >> That
that that
and he kind of did like a few of the things that he normally
does like, oh, did you know that he agrees with Asmin Gold
that I'm bad? Doesn't that tell you all you need to know about
him? doesn't you know did you know that he agrees with Nick Fuentes
that I'm bad kind of interesting that he's agreeing with Asmin
Gold and Nick Fuentes don't you think huh meanwhile you know
Nick Fuentes agrees with Hassan about Israel right so does that
mean that how many comments have we made about Hassan place training
andor shocking andor abusing animals in the hour we've watched
I feel like there's been at least 10
okay I don't know seems like a little >> adjacent to white
nationalists
really makes you think he posted a video 43 minutes ago called
they tried to stop me
He is Donald Trump. Okay, this is Donald Trump after the guilty
verdict in his criminal trial. This is Donald.
Hok boy says, "Tell Quement I could write a perfect tweet for
him. I have a certain flare for this. I can get you on stream,
bro. Trust." Any comment on that? Oh, silence. Silence is violence
in this case. I'm going to go ahead and respond for him. I I
think I think Queman lets other people tweet for him. Okay. He
protects his Twitter very dearly.
But if you've got a way to do it, I listen. I'm I'm willing to
hear it, okay? If you got a way to do it, we can make it work.
Almost certainly. >> Don't [__] Trump. After
the criminal indictments, they tried to indict me. He is Donald
Trump. You guys, >> we got like five minutes remaining.
They're going to do an >> They're not trying to take me
down
because of what I said. No, no, no. They're trying to take me
down because they're really going after you and I'm standing
in the way. He's their Is HDS contagious? Did Hutch catch this
from Ethan?
No. Um, Hutch was one of the people that a lot of Dusty's audience
moved to when they weren't watching him and he's just had his
opinions shaped like pretty quickly over time
is how I see it. Maybe maybe that's not entirely correct. I do
like he probably drafted off of a lot of the liberal circle to
begin with, right? Like he's friends with a lot of people who
were friends with Destiny who whether or not they collab with
him, they were all friends sort of share a lot of the same beliefs,
right? Hutch also watches Destiny probably. I would imagine
>> I would imagine.
>> So-called audience capture. Yeah, basically like there's
just a lot of donations in being
this guy.
It's good. It's a good living. Okay. It's a good living. >> I
did everything right and they shot colored me.
I did everything right.
He is Donald Trump. He is Donald Trump. >> Introductory
speech. >> Hush said Destiny was the one who pointed out
the dangers of the left to him. Probably. I think um Destiny
was also the one who pointed out the doxing to him almost a year
after it originally
What a nice guy. I wonder if that had anything to do with the
fact that he didn't like the person who he told Hutch doxed him.
Wonder if it could have anything to do with that at all. >> Sure.
Not introduction because they're going to intro me. Intro the
moderator. The moderator is going to intro me. I'm going to go
out there. We're going to flip it over. We're going to flip it
over to the regular live stream. you'll see us on the regular
live stream and then after that uh we'll say our goodbyes and
we'll peace out and then I I will do the CBC interview and Q&A
with the student fans
and turn >> Oh, ChappieD over in the Hutch chat asks which
Fentes position on Israel does Hassan agree with again >> defiance
against anti-imperialism
>> uh the that's the position that is okay Chappid obviously
you don't even know that that Hassan and Fuentes both think is
okay obviously >> but sovereignty in order to maintain
national sovereignty in order to maintain their cultures in order
to make sure that their citizens don't get uh the worst end of
the bargain as they have been consistently with American international
trade engineering. There are new >> Oh, Kuba Kuba Kuba.
He's announced that he's going to be on some kind of a
>> His perspective has been shaped by firsthand experience
with contemporary backlighting and authoritarian politics in
both Turkey and the United States. His work presents a new form
of historic political media, lending contary activism and community
building in ways that are reshaping generations to engage politics.
So, please join me in >> Oh, we're going to get a speech.
Okay,
listen up. You idiot pearls.
You idiot peasants.
Your vanguard is listening. Your Vanguard is speaking. He will
tell you. He will teach you. >> I bet. I bet.
>> Uh, I'm confused as to what Hutch does outside of hate
watching Hassan. Okay, so he watched
I guess. Do we count Pisco versus Ogre Boy is hate watching Hassan?
I feel like we do. Unfortunately,
there's all the Pisco stuff with the Hassan versus um Hassan
versus Pisco stuff and then it was watching Destiny.
He watches Destiny as well. He he hate watches Hassan and watches
Destiny too. Thomas Freeman didn't get that [laughter] kind of
reception.
Anyway, no disrespect to all the previous guests. I'm actually
probably going to deliver a much worse speech than everyone that
came before me and then everyone that will come after me, including
but not limited to Rachel Matau,
especially considering that I just found out that I'm sharing
a stage and a program with Thomas Freedman and Rachel Matau approximately
10 minutes before I got out of the car. And uh I walked in and
then they told me, "Oh, you have a speech." And I was like, "Oh,
yeah." You know, like like a two-minute speech, something like
that. And they're like, "You signed on for 15 minutes." And I
thought to myself, "Well, I done did it again. Um, this is probably
what, like the 20th time, uh, that I've done one of these sorts
of, uh, you know, college speeches where I just come out on stage
and start blurting it out. And, uh, I have no understanding of
what the what the event is, but I'm going to try to do my very
best, especially considering that I speak for 8 hours uninterrupted
or usually interrupted with, >> well, that's just unprofessional
>> chat. It's not I mean, he's obviously lying. I'm sorry.
As soon as he says, I feel like anytime when you don't have a
speech written, when this actually happens, you don't say it,
right? You just obviously go out and say this because it's funny.
You're like leaning into it. Oh, I'm not really all that prepared,
right? Actually, I
some Netflix series about politics I watched recently, the the
prime minister some country did this. They like went up on on
stage and like did this whole thing where they'd written out
on uh their hand like part of their speech or something and then
it looked to everybody like they were sloppy and doing it off
the cuff and then the person saw him like actually uh like they
saw his notes for the speech like oh it was like he was super
prepared for the whole thing you know it's like a double fake.
Okay, >> it's not going to be too [laughter] difficult
I hope. But today obviously we're going to be talking about >> I'm
too cool for the uh for the official format. I'm too [__]
cool for the official format. one of my favorite subjects to
>> I couldn't prepare. I'm too busy streaming every day.
Like what discuss according to all my naysayers uh including
the uh the CIA I believe. I don't know if they're in the room
right now. Uh sorry I you know I'm sorry that you guys couldn't
stop me from coming to uh Vancouver. >> There's a J in
the name.
I'm assuming it has something to do with Israel. >> But
I'm going to be >> granted with the tier one membership.
Thanks so much. Appreciate it. >> I'm going to be talking
about one of my to be fair. I do assume anything that has a J
in it has to do with as well. Hutch. We share that in common.
So, I'm not gonna hold that one against >> favorite subject
according to my haters, which is America bad.
I think a lot of Canadians have uh learned that lesson if they
weren't aware of this con. >> Talk about cheap applause.
I mean, my god, you know, comedians talk about getting cheap
applause. We're like, how about those Tigers? You know, like
that kind of go to Canada and say America bad.
Talk about cheap applause. Come on. >> Except for the Albertans
that America is, as a matter of fact, somewhat of a parasitic
force in the global new world order. And um it was actually one
of my uh only failed predictions of 2025 when I thought that
Pierre Polybe am I saying that right? >> Poly
doesn't matter. Doesn't matter. This college campus is so woke
you.
>> Anyway, one of those guys that's usually very well I
guess he wasn't really but usually the conservative party from
where we're standing in America always tries to be American for
some weird reason. And I guess because of Donald Trump that really
backfired spectacularly last election cycle for you guys. And
I I thought he had a shot a real shot until I found out that
Canadians do value dignity and sovereignty. He he did have a
real shot. It was literally the most cataclysmic like
destruction of a political party and campaign that's ever happened
in Canadian history. I that I'm aware of. Okay. Like being that
far ahead in the polls to just totally getting decimated over
one issue. It was insane. >> And don't want to be annexed
by the United States of America, which is a very healthy attitude
to have, especially considering that um I think >> Laui,
he really thought PP had a shot. Bro, the guy the guy led the
polls massively by like double digits for weeks and weeks and
weeks and it was like a month out from the election that it flipped
>> with this last iteration of >> Canadians value
their sovereignty by taking elections seriously. Well, you know,
I thought I thought the other guy had a shot, but it turns out
Canadians take elections seriously and they voiced their they
made their voices heard and rejected somebody who embraced the
person who I couldn't even, you know, meaningfully oppose during
an election >> of our uh our beautiful President Donald
Trump's attempts at annexing, forcibly annexing Greenland, uh
which is a part of of our NATO security cooperation. Someone
should tell Donald Trump that. um um especially after that we
saw uh many European leaders openly take to the stage at Davos
and say we'd rather be happy vassels than angry slaves. And I
thought about that quite a bit and I thought about Mark Carney's
speech, Mark Carney's speech quite a bit. Um and I think that
there is a failure of the previous liberal international order
and consensus. Uh and and I don't think it's necessarily just
Donald Trump, even though we like to talk about him as the harbinger
of doom. The reality of the matter is these systems have been
collapsing for quite a while. If you're in the third world, if
you're in a developing nation, you already know exactly what
it's like to be on the receiving end of endless amounts of bloodshed
and domination. Now, of course, people of my political background
have been talking about this for years. Um, Lenin was one of
those people that talked about IT QUITE A BIT. Imperialism being
an absolute necessity uh as a as a global capitalist order as
profit rates have a tendency to decline. And we've seen this
endless militarism and endless domination in the global south
in in uh countries that are in the periphery at the behest of
super profits for international capital.
But unfortunately now America's appetite for instability and
all of the potential promises of said instability for international
capital has put new targets in its crosshairs as Markney and
many others have talked about middle powers. We're talking about
the European Union, Canada, and many other countries that are
stuck between what seems like American domination and uh the
the global liberal capitalist hegemony and potentially the rise
of regional powers such as Russia that do not shy away from irudidentist
action and often times violent military conquest and the behemoth
of manufacturing that is China. Now, as you guys already know,
Brics Nations uh have realized that this
>> I'm shocked that I I'm actually shocked that Hutch hasn't
tried to cut in because nothing Hassan's saying is like
really even objectionable at this point. Like, this is all fine.
This is all like, at least in terms of the geopolitics, it's
basically all paint by numbers, right? But I I'm really shocked
he's plagiarizing Carney. Well, he's literally referencing Carney's
speech right now. I don't know if I'd say he's plagiarizing Carney.
He literally said, "I watched Carney's speech." And then he's
talking about the speech, right? But um I I just thought Hutch
would want to step in and like totally disagree with something
random. And I I haven't seen that. So that's, you know, he's
he's outperforming where I thought it would be. This bargain
of American domination was not always going to work out well
for them. And that's the reason why they have sought out alternatives
and try to create different trade agreements and and maybe even
currency cooperative agreements with China specifically to at
times leverage their relationship that they have with the United
States of America. And I've been a longtime advocate in developing
European sovereignty and developing sovereignty for countries
like Canada. And now I believe is the time for these middle powers
to be able to develop sovereignty once again. Help elect a chaos
agent like Donald Trump who then goes on to isolate America on
the world stage, shrink from our role that we've had for decades
now. Fracture our international partnerships.
>> See, this is the problem.
Oh, I I actually have like criticisms of Hutch now, though.
It's not Hassan's actually correct here and he's correct because
he listen did Hutch listen to Carney speech Trump to the rest
of the world to the middle powers Trump is a symptom
of the American disease okay it's not Trump is not the primary
driving factor of this this was happening this was going to happen
regardless of Trump that you have a populist disease in your
country that is going to take over that is going to cause like
all of these issues that people have been predicting for a while.
It is. It's going to happen. Okay. And so we have to deal with
that. And it's not going to go away when Trump's not elected
anymore either. It's going to be here like forever. It's going
well for the foreseeable future. Like we have to adapt to a new
meta essentially. There's going to be something some new order
that develops. And this is Carne trying to say this is what I
think the new order should be. But it's it's not
not electing Trump would have delayed this a little bit, but
it would not have prevented it from happening. that most people
seem to at least a lot of world leaders, you know, they they
can see, okay, Donald Trump like clearly tried to overthrow an
election. He is super callous. He is super like anybody who has
like
the only reason he's getting elected is because there's an an
overwhelming will behind him that is is
undeniable,
right? like there's some will behind him that's pushing him forward
that despite the fact that he's like fairly gross, he's fairly
off-putting to a lot of people, they will still vote for him.
It's I think it's mostly just animous, mostly just um you know,
he's the personification of people feeling like the economy doesn't
work for them, feeling like their lives are getting worse. That's
that's kind of what's driving his force here. And as long as
that continues, America is not going to be a reliable partner
for people. quite literally like tear up trade agreements,
pursue a policy of blanket tariffs, engage in economic warfare
against our allies.
He is an accelerationist, bro. And now he's like gleeful. You
know what I mean? He's like gleeful. He almost cannot contain
his excitement for the chaos that comes with Donald Trump and
then using that as a pretense to push the world in a more multipolar
direction. It's just accelerationism is what it is. I mean, he
is like gleeful about it. >> And I fear that >> the
hypocrisy of us on here is astounding, especially because he
can't even recognize it. praising a nation for doing something
he isn't willing to advocate for himself rather refuses to do.
You mean like rejecting the Trumpy candidate on the Canadian
ballot >> if these countries don't do it, specifically
Canada? I worry that American domination will at first uh at
first look like the terrorist negot >> I think that he
is I don't know if he'll ever come out and say it. I really doubt
it. But I am so convinced just listening to the first like five
minutes of the speech that he's happy that Donald Trump
I think he is happy that Donald Trump won. I think he's happy
with that outcome. I don't think he will ever say that out loud,
but a big hutch knows what accelerationism means. Yeah. I just
I this is a lot of it's just it's weird.
Like I seriously just see it as there's like a demand for a level
of hate for Hassan that the that like reality can't fulfill.
So they do just sort of start creatively writing after a while.
It's a little bizarre to be honest. I mean you could get up here
and be like, "Oh, it's cringe to talk about how this is like
imperialism."
But there is something to the e there's something to a comparison
of economic imperialism and the control the US had over the global
economic system and how they were able to leverage that against
countries in 2025
Like there is something there that is like they did have dominance
or uh dominion over a lot of these countries in a way that they
never flexed before and then they suddenly flexed and everybody's
like whoa what the [__] what the [__]
>> I think he he thinks that this is >> I don't think
it's insane. I don't think it's an insane compar Yeah, it's not
an insane comparison. better because it's going to create chaos
the conservative
>> to get into put into Game of Thrones >> Oh, I
forgot he did this. I heard this last night. Was I watching a
clip last night? I heard this last night. I can't remember if
I was watching the stream.
>> I think he is happy that Donald Trump won. I think he's
happy with that outcome. I don't think he will ever say that
out loud, but I think he he thinks that this is better cuz it's
going to create chaos that can serve as a ladder to get into
put into Game of Thrones language. I think he's happy Trump won
>> that Donald Trump has seen. Wow. Game of Thrones reference.
Let's go. Let's go. Why has Game of Thrones become so relevant
lately? I don't I don't know, man. He already said accelerationism.
Why didn't he just stick with that? I don't know why it has thrown
around the truth. And then and in the worst case scenario, complete
military annexation.
Now that might sound terrifying to you guys, but we have the
most peaceful option ahead of us, at least for the time being.
Because this growth that we are seeing, this change, this this
nuclear option of trade, this destruction of international agreements
that America was not only the safeguard of, but also the architects
of are coming to a close. What comes next is up to all of us.
And by that, I mean not just international, >> oh capital,
capital owners of different sorts, bourgeoa, small business owners,
mama and pop land, landlords and the like. I'm talking about
you, the people, the workers, you who comprise the >> Oh
my god. that apparently touch off the the you people.
>> It's like the Bane speech in the Dark Knight Rises,
you know? He really guys, he really sees himself as like the
second coming of Vladimir Lennon. >> Like he really sees
himself that way. >> It is so cringe. >> Wow.
That's like uh Bane and Lenin. Same kind of guy. Really? >> It's
so cringe.
>> And the quicker >> Wow.
I forget. Is it
Hold on. What is this? Is it the Is it the the Bill of Rights
or is it It's some major US document that starts with we the
people is that it's the Bill of Rights, isn't it? Or is it the
Constitution? Which one is it? Which which is the one that we
the people hold these truths to be self-evident?
Which one is that? Which one is that? Americans. Where are my
Americans at?
Declaration of Independence. Oh, right.
Right. National treasure. I
I can't believe I forgot that. Oh, is it the Bill of Rights?
Wait, is it the Bill of Rights? Okay.
That's what I thought was it was the Bill of Rights. So, it's
just to me I'm like the first thing he thought of when it was
like the people
was Batman and me I was like, isn't that the thing from from
your founding document? It's the Declaration of Independence.
Okay. Okay. Isn't that like from your founding document? Isn't
that like the start of your country is we the people hold these
truths to be self-evident? I just I to me I was like you're a
politics guy and your first thought was Batman. Google it. I
did try to Google it but I didn't I didn't Google it correctly.
I just Googled the uh the Bill of Rights because I thought that's
what it was but he really sees himself as like the second coming
of Vladimir Lennon. Like he he really sees himself that way.
>> You meant Hutch. >> It's so cringe.
>> So I thought it was goofy as hell. >> And the
quicker we develop >> the Dwight TR speech at the uh paper
conference or whatever >> for ourselves both in our work
>> got them belongs to you people. Oh, I'm mixing them
together. Okay. Okay. >> The people's constitution. We
hold these
Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. >> Places both
in our universities. The quicker we organize for ourselves, the
eas
impression. You just did a Bane impression. Hold on. Don't want
to miss out on Hutch's. I don't want to I would never want to
talk over Hutch's Bane impression, guys. Okay. We don't want
to miss his Bane impression. >> For ourselves, both in
our work. Gotham belongs to you and the people. We give it back
to you. Do with it what you >> Okay. Okay, I'll get I'll
give it to that was actually way better than I thought it was
going to be. That was actually pretty accurate. That was not
terrible.
Did I have that sped up? I had that sped up. I'm actually slow
down belongs to you. >> This is like the most competent
thing I've ever seen Hutch do. This is like we found his thing.
We found a thing that Hutch is good at. >> The paper conference
or whatever for ourselves both in our work. >> Gotham belongs
to you the people.
We give it back to you.
Do with it what you will. and cast out the capital owners.
>> They're decad. >> No, I thought that was pretty
good.
>> Places both in our universe. >> He didn't he didn't
commit though. You see how he got embarrassed of himself? >> You
see how he got embarrassed of
>> They're decadent lives >> places both in our universities.
The quicker we organize for ourselves, the easier it will be
for all of us to preserve said national sovereignty and to hopefully
make it as cost. This is the this is like the video essaist who
does all the the video essays and the lefty people.
Your punishment must be more severe. Shocks.
Wow. W how the conduit guy.
So cool. Love to see it. as possible for America to continue
dominating the world and engineering whatever kind of design
they have. >> Now, my role in this struggle
is chief
I will obviously
not be fighting in the streets against the
guardians of capital, the police state,
the industrial military complex,
the military-industrial complex. I will of
not be joining you in the streets, but I will cover it on my
stream while making thousands of dollars every stream.
Wow. Now, I understand some of you guys might resent that,
okay? But we are all handed our lot in life.
I did not choose to be super hot. I did not choose to be smarter
than all of you.
I did not choose to be a capable, charismatic leader.
God chose that for me. And [clears throat] who am I to deny my
purest essence?
But I'll be rooting for you guys out there in the streets. I'll
be pulling for you
and uh I'll cover it on my stream. That's just as good as currency.
I The way I'm going to contribute to this movement is through
exposure.
And you can't really put a value on that.
If I pull up you guys like fighting and dying in the streets
on my stream,
what is that worth? I don't even know, dude. If we have to if
we outlaw
AI deep fakes. Okay, we might have to do something similar to
this. It's like actually kind of weird to watch you just like
creatively write fantasies about another dude on stream all the
time. It's a little It's a little disturbing. Okay. Yeah, it's
like I'm getting weird vibes from this. Okay,
I'm getting very weird vibes now.
>> I will put >> He's like He's like literally not
listening to the speech. He hears like trigger words in the speech
and just goes off on some rant about a thing he's been like dreaming
about in the background. Put the message out there.
>> LISTEN UP, YOU BALD FRAUD.
ALSO, make sure you sign up for Amazon Prime for the low low
price of $130 a
And then use your Prime sub on me. If you don't have a Prime
sub or can't afford Prime,
I will take paid subs. Gifted subs are not as ideal, but I will
take them. Of course, a decent percentage of that money will
go straight to Jeff Bezos,
really not that much. Right. Right guys, don't feel too bad about
it. I'm not funneling that much money to Jeffrey Bezos. Okay.
>> Is Is Hutch gonna stop streaming on Twitch or
Where's the criticism coming from? I
>> I saw he literally tells people they can watch without
subbing.
I just some special stuff we got here. Okay. >> Piece of
this in action when I went to
because American domination
has often uh put its crosshairs on developing nations as I've
talked about before. Iraq,
>> He's going to do the line. He's going to say that [clears throat]
fascism is imperialism turned inwards. He's going to do the line
>> as recently uh as we saw in Venezuela where the American
government kidnapped the leader of Venezuela and his wife in
and is facilitating a mock trial, a sham trial at this moment.
You don't have to love the Venezuelan uh you don't have to love
the Venezuelan government. You don't. I don't. Just to be clear,
I don't know a lot about them. But what I do know, I don't. Hyperinflation,
guys. I'm just finding out
I don't know if you guys heard about this.
It turns out
hyperinflation due to incompetent economic policy is actually
pretty not
Did you guys know this? Just now finding out. Wow.
Turns out it's not good. What is this dude on about? I mean,
he's definitely he's definitely talking about socialism in Venezuela
and the hyperinflation in their economy, the destruction of their
currency, which did happen. Okay, that definitely happened.
It's actually not good.
You'd think it's like, whoa, now I'm making $5,000 an hour. This
is dope. Turns out not good. It's actually not good. You don't
have to be a communist or a socialist to to recognize what that
says for the international. >> You think H ever wonders
why this is so easy on his stream, but like anytime he goes to
talk to somebody, he gets blown the out like horribly. Like just
completely horribly every single time.
You think that ever strikes a little bit just in the back of
his head a little bit? He like has these fights with shadows
all the time and then he goes to talk to somebody just gets blown
out again and again and again. national order, which was something
that many European and even Canadian partners did not recognize
initially as they celebrated this action only to receive the
exact same type of lack of autonomy when Donald Trump put his
crosshairs on Greenland.
It shouldn't take for Trump to go after a uh white partner country
in Europe, a NATO partner country in Europe for people
>> land really in Europe to wisen up to our grand design.
And when I say our, I'm talking about the American government
>> narrow demise. Thank you so much for 6 months. Appreciate
it. But the international destabilization that we have caused
came back into the homeront as imperialism often does in the
form of fascism.
[__] told you now that these filthy pearls in the
streets of Minnesota got a got us got a little
of what America's been doing all over the world.
>> It's like a it's just like a bad Hassan roleplay stream.
[laughter] Like spends a significant amount of his stream role
playing as Sassan.
Is this a thing? I didn't even realize. >> Now, do you
guess what? >> Like, and I don't mean role playing as in
he's like acting like him sincere. I mean like he's trying to
roleplay and like be a caricature of Assan for a lot of his stream.
>> It's very funny. >> Imperialism, but it's turned
inwards. Just as fascism arose from the failures of liberalism
only but a 100 years ago, the new wave of fascism is no longer
seen as a revol. >> I actually think that fascism arose
in part because of the [clears throat] economic devast devastation
of the, you know, treaty of Versailles and the
insane reparations that Germany was forced to pay that they just
didn't have the money to pay for. I feel like it was more than
just like
liberal democracy and capitalism that led to fascism but >> revolutionary
movement but instead a movement away from liberalism.
The American Republican party is now transitioning away from
a liberal conservative party. >> Oh, are you making the
point here that Italy was literally
Is it the ant or the No, it' be the Allies in World War I as
well, right? The untaunt were the bad guys. I bro I I did like
a whole um obviously I learned about World War I in school
but I I literally remember nothing except Treaty of Versailles
like almost nothing at all about World War I. All gone in my
brain. World War II enthusiast. Well, World War II is way cooler.
Yeah, fascism obviously started in Italy. I'm talking about was
the um was so the winning side included Italy was just the point
that um whisper in the dark was making basically that fascism
arose in Italy so it rose out of somewhere where there wasn't
the treaty of Versailles he's talking about Nazism which is like
slightly different from original fascism
like I but I think it has a lot of roots in fascism as well so
but originally like fascism did rise in Italy although I do think
it rises out of difficulty as well right? Like there were there
were severe economic I guess um there's like a severe economic
downturn in Italy as well, right? That they were dealing with
to a fascist party.
And as fascists often do, they are invested in domination and
cruelty for cruelty's sake. Which is why I'm prepared to commit
here and now to help JD Vance win in 2028 if Gavin Newsome is
the nominee for the Democratic party. It doesn't have to make
sense.
Don't question the >> And the reason why I brought up Minneapolis,
Minnesota, and my experiences there is because as of today, Tom
Hman has decided that they are retreating the ICE occupation
that unfolded in Minneapolis, Minnesota. And the only reason
>> Yes. And the only reason that happened was because the
people got together, they organized, and they protected their
neighbors. They were resisting ICE.
They were resisting the Trump administration.
They were not resisting
This is what they do. This is all they do. They leech onto protest
movements.
Why are you leeching my liberal protest, my liberal ICE protests?
It's like, bro, I that see why are you trying to gateep a protest
that you didn't go to? Could you explain
Could you Could you explain why you're trying to gateep a protest
you didn't go to? I I'm sorry, man.
And they try to make it about a broader struggle against
what they call in their minds capitalism and imperialism.
This is all they do. They were not taking to the streets because
they want to seize the means of production.
They did it because they >> Did he say that? I'm prepared
to commit here and now to the >> Hold on. What What did
Hassan say
>> So, the reason why I brought up Minneapolis, Minnesota,
and my experiences there is because as of today, Tom Hman has
decided that they are retreating the ICE occupation that unfolded
in Minneapolis, Minnesota. And the only reason
Yes. And the only reason that happened was because the people
got together, they organized, and they protected their >> They
were resisting ICE. He literally makes no commentary at all.
He just says they organized, they got together, they organized,
they protected their
I Okay, now I guess we're going to read in that this was about
communism. >> Resisting the Trump administration.
They were not resisting capitalism.
This is what they do. This is all they do. They leech onto protest
movements
and they try to make it about a broader struggle against
what they call in their minds capitalism and imperialism.
This is all they do. They were not taking to the streets because
they want to seize Hassan is delusional.
Okay. It was because Ham was there. He did it. Kamla would have
sent more ICE agents in apparently. Dude, I Han is
>> The means of production.
They did it because they killed two Americans and were terrorizing
Minneapolis.
That's why they were there. >> And while there was tremendous
cruelty, kidnappings taking place on a daily basis and community
defense and people that got shot and killed like Renee Good and
Alex Peretti. Rest in power. I am
so triggered right now. I am so triggered right now. >> By
what? >> Did he do everything in his power?
Did he really leave it all out there on the court? I mean, he's
talking about the current administration in pretty stark terms.
He's talking about the current trajectory that America is on
as a result of this administration winning
in pretty stark terms, right? Rest in power, brother. I'll see
you in Valhalla. You know, that to me is like the Cash Patel.
to you in Valhalla, brother. Okay.
Did he really leave it all out on the court to like stop this
administration from winning? >> Alex Prey, staunch anti-
capitalist Marxism revolutionary.
Are they saying that like jokingly? I'm sorry, but I do feel
like the people who get like super soy who like actually will
go and fight with uh police at those protests, they tend to all
fall into the like perform what we would call the performative
like leftist camp, right? I do feel like there's a good chance
when you see somebody going up and kicking the tail light out
of a vehicle. I feel like they often have like some anti- capitalist
communist views. That's my experience.
I I'm sorry. That just tends to be the case, man. They usually
have more extreme views. They see this as like a more extreme
thing. >> Winning that would have prevented Alexie from
dying.
Can he really say that he did everything in his power to prevent
that from happening >> and now he wants to
treat Alex as a prop in his
larie ridiculous fantastical
communist fantasy like delusional fantasy rest in power brother
I'll help JD Vance in 2028 but rest in power brother you know
what the man >> truly disturbing like a [__]
I don't even know, man. He's like a He's like a kids in the hall
character, you know? Not quite like Saturday Night Live, but
you know, some kind of He's like a Monty Python sketch is what
he is.
He's a caricature from a Monty Python movie is what he is.
I wonder if it would change Hush's opinion if those people were
like if you saw their beliefs and they were like just actually
like anti- capitalist like communist revolutionary types. I I
literally don't know. But what if you discovered that? Would
that change his opinion on whose protest they are? And
I I don't know. By the way, I don't think you should have By
the way, that shouldn't really change your opinion because your
opinion should be. It's just like protesting against like an
authoritarian regime. It's not It's not a protest where you need
to split it into like liberals liberals protest over here, communist
protest over here. Like libertarians protest over here. It's
just like no, this thing is bad. I don't know. Nobody claims
it. Nobody gets to own it. I don't know. The people did not stand
down. >> So weird. >> Under -35°
F. I don't know if you guys use Fahrenheit here. Minus 35° Fahrenheit
weather. It was very cold.
>> 50 60,000 people got together and did a day of direct
action. Um somewhat of a general strike. They call it a general
strike. It's not the same as the traditional general strike,
but there was a day of action. Small businesses from the community
also participated in this blackout.
And in the aftermath of all of this participation in community
defense,
ICE was forced to back away. This is the most peaceful option.
JFK has said those who make peaceful revolution impossible
make violent retribution inevitable.
>> JFK has said that. >> I think someone misqued.
I think it's uh violent violent revolution, not violent >> Those
who make Is that the exact quote? Those who make peaceful revolution
impossible will make violent revolution inevitable. Remarks on
the first anniversary
of the Alliance for
13 March 1962.
Now I want to look for the full
Was JFK saying that communism was cool there or is Hassan misusing
this? It's like I don't I don't think that's Hassan's point here
again. I wonder what else is in that speech. >> No, I think
>> for progress.
>> I think Hutch wants to look at this speech because he
thinks it's gonna be like against communism or something and
he's gonna say actually you can't talk about you can't talk about
communism
read this. Have a choice. You do. You
You do. I'm just saying there's like a lot of things that they
do like they reference the letter from Birmingham. The the Desa
guy is kind of funny. Yes. Go down the rabbit hole in desperation.
Let's go,
>> Hey, like read this [clears throat] like five minutes
to read this. >> Do you guys mind if I read this?
>> Do we have a choice? >> You do. You do.
>> You do. I'm just saying there's like a lot of things
that they do. Like they reference the letter from Birmingham
jail a lot. MLK MLK Jr. They talk about like the white moderate
and just like ignore the rest of the speech. And there's it is
a great pleasure for Mrs. Kennedy and for me, the vice president
and Mrs. Johnson, and for the members of Congress to welcome
the ambassadorial core of our hemisphere,
our longtime friends to the White House today. I'm not going
to read this. I take it all back. I'm going to book I'll probably
violent >> kind of long and I fear that violent >> kind
of long. It's kind of long. I'll probably take like 10 minutes
to read that. I fear that violence might become necessary. Those
who make peaceful revolution impossible make violent retribution
inevitable.
>> Well, it's not retribution, it's revolution. But >> and
I fear that violent retribution as the last option. Which is
why I'm here to talk today to you guys about what it means that
the international order is falling apart. The old world is dying.
A new world struggles to be born from its ashes. Now is the time
for monsters. Grochi said that. I hope I didn't destroy that
quote. I was trying to paraphrase it. Um, and on that note, I
think I'm ready to go. I did 15 minutes. I don't >> You
know who he sounds like right there? >> Like the modern
founder of socialism, like a European philosopher who's like
one of the founders of socialism and what led to Nazism and fascism.
Actually,
Grahamshy, is that how you say it? That's like uh he's political
philosopher, right? I know. I know. He's supposed to be like
he some of his works were like the underpinnings for the original
fascism stuff, but I think he was a socialist guy. >> Now
is the time for monsters. Why? >> Also, I'll just point
out he went 15 minutes pretty easily. Obviously had a bunch of
quotes in there that he was willing to use and seemed pretty
ready to go 15
>> monsters.
He's the Surfs TV for liberals better yet. Oh, he is like the
surfs actually.
He is kind of like the surfs, isn't he? Why do we need monsters?
like dinosaurs, like Godzilla, like what are we talking about?
Um, who's that? Who's that young US representative that was in
the wheelchair?
It was like Jordan Peterson. Yeah, it was like Jordan Peterson,
but I'm thinking of the kid that like quoted him. Who's that?
Who's that young guy? And he only served one term. The old world
is dying and the new world struggles to be born. Now is the time
of monsters. Antonio Gshy.
Wow. Wow. >> Cthorne. Madison Cawthorne
mothers you need to raise little monsters. Remember that he was
like quoting Jordan Peterson. >> So we have talked about
Madison
all the disturbed by the audience.
>> I don't I don't know where he's going with this. I don't
even know how the time for that reaction who loves what he has
to say. Take a look. Our culture today is trying to completely
deasculate all of the young men in our culture. I mean, you can
look at the testosterone levels in young men today and they are
lower than throughout all of history. And there's a lot of reasons
for this that we can get into later, but my friends, they're
trying to demask >> sedentary lifestyles,
diet, >> lack of sleep, you know, >> how did he how
did he pivot to this?
Not because like you raised your son and gave him too many hugs
or whatever. ulate the young men in this country because they
don't want people who are going to stand up. >> And so
I'm telling you all of you moms here, the people who I said were
the most vicious in our uh in our movement, if you were raising
a young man, please raise them to be a monster. >> Raise
he's
>> the international order is falling apart. The old world
is dying.
A new world struggles to be born from its ashes. Now is the time
for monsters.
>> Jesus Christ. I actually don't think you should raise
your little boys to be monsters and I don't think that we need
in the context of geopolitics right now. That would be preferable.
Dude, I'm uh Hutch does think he think he uh needs monsters.
Okay.
And there couple different things that is constant, you know,
deferring to Pisco, getting Pisco to come and beat up Ogre Boy
for, you know, Hutch does believe he needs monsters. He's not
willing to admit it. Okay. Well, that we don't do that. But
sounds good on a bumper sticker, right? You know,
by the way, that quote was given in like the 1930s talking about
how, hey, the current world order is sort of buckling at the
seams and we're going to now is the time of monsters. 15 years
away from the Holocaust starting and finishing.
I'm just I'm just saying it seems like that guy had a good head
on his shoulders. the guy he's quoting seemed to understand that
now is the time for crazy that was about to pop off. Okay.
Like that that quote couldn't have been more accurate if you
tried. It's like the most accurate quote that's ever been given.
I don't know. It's when when did all the um the genocides happen
in USSR as well. Was that preWorld War II or after when like
the hood happened? Hold must been after World War II, right?
I actually don't know. 30s. Okay. Well, there you go. Graham,
she was on the money then.